so today you guys may have seen the
video where I decorated a tech Christmas
tree them all in everything's everything
period it's like the kids say well today
I wanted to decorate one specifically
with the iPhone at 10 ours because the
10 ours are so beautiful and I thought
they would make an incredible Christmas
tree decoration this poor little
Christmas tree has definitely seen
better days so we've got to kind of
spread these little branches out may not
look like a hot mess it definitely got
smashed in storage I love the holidays
so much and everyone's in a cheerful
festive mood and I'm decorating an
iPhone Christmas tree would you have it
any other way I mean no you actually
probably wouldn't so let's plug this in
oh my goodness it's so festive
no oh shoot well we have one dead ball
that really ruins the Christmas spirit
we still have some of these that were in
the packaging from when I unbox these
phones so I'm hoping that they will
actually stay on here but this thing's
gonna fall over there's absolutely no
way to seem able to even hold this up oh
yeah that's really a look some people
will say Justine have you run out of
video ideas and if I say to them this
was a video idea and now it's a reality
can you even believe so you may also be
wondering who the winners were of the
iPhone 10 are and I've had pro or
macbook contest those were announced on
Jonathan's Twitter and I also retweeted
it so be sure to check out that sea-ice
and see if you were the winners and if
you were you probably already know that
you were contacted because you won so
the whole thing but congratulations to
the winners so this is looking pretty
good kind of so in the holiday spirit
can you handle it
here's archery topper can I get this
even stay up here like this is so silly
I mean I've got a tech Christmas tree I
have an iPhone 10 our Christmas tree
what more could one ask for I'm not even
sure I thought also because I have some
of these ear pods and I would add these
on as well I'm just trying to get them
all to stay in the front here just when
you thought you've seen it all you
haven't seen anything what a good look
this is really coming together no I only
have two left let's add some biggest to
this
I like the ear pod look though that
looks really good
like this is something that they should
probably put in the Apple store like if
they want to use this you guys it's here
it's here for you this looks absolutely
terrible actually this looks really bad
I had some high hopes but that's
probably the problem usually when I have
low expectations for things things
turned out really well
so here's the problem as only looks good
from one angle well it does barely even
looks good from that angle all right
well I guess a lot on another cable
because I've got it here
what other phones do I have I feel like
this needs no phones maybe we can add
some pieces it's not 10 R but it's still
effective oh this is really nice in an
Apple case but it's oh there's a case
inside of it the things that you do for
fun and for YouTube Apple watch bands
just to really spice it up cuz you've
got to get in the holiday spirit guys
we've got to get super festive haters
will say it's photoshopped Muroto Scott
I am so blown away by my creativity and
shocked with just how beautiful this is
I mean okay it's pretty bad but well I
want to know what are your holiday plans
do you have holiday plans do not have
holiday plans and if you don't that's
totally fine - happy holidays
I am hyped about this tree I gotta go
find a good place to put this it's like
this has got to be pretty heavy oh yeah
this is incredibly heavy I can't even
like I can barely even pick it up it's
gonna fall over
well happy holidays again guys Merry
Christmas if you celebrate I love you
guys and I will see you in my next video
hopefully I'll have some other fun
themed holiday things for you does
anything else would you like to see me
make leave of the comments below
[Music]
[Applause]